بكل الاحوال
هذا بيخلينا نطرح سؤال البلد يعني بشكل
عام انت من مواليد مواليد في حلب لكنك
حموي المنبت يعني
العائله حمويه والولد حسب ما قرانا كان
المنجد يعمل في التنجيد وانت يبدو العائلي
كلها بتهتم
بالرسم الى حد ما هو السؤال انت يعني
البلدين اللي البلد اللي خلقت فيه
والبلد اللي قتل منه الوالد ورجعت له
اتعلمت فيه اني تقريبا شهد ماساه كبيره شو
احساسك تجاهك تدمير حلب كامله خاصه باسماء
القديمه
وعمران التاريخ
حينها كان في باريس لم تشهد يعني ما عاش
ربما بعد العائلي دفع عثمان هذه المساء
شو شعورك شو احساس شو بتقدر تعمل يعني
انا صانع جمال ما بقدر اساوي غير الجمال
يعني ما بقدر اسوي شيء لانه
ما بحب ادخل
السياسي مسكان كثير حزينه الشعور طبعا
قاتل انا مرضت بعدين يعني وقت كنت في
سوريا ما قدرت اوقف على رجلي يعني
ماذا توقف على رجلي ضليت شهر يعني مريض
وبالاخر
[موسيقى]
ما قدرت اتحمل يعني خراب كل هذا الخراب
وقت حمى انت كنت في باريس كان في باريس
بحوادث 82
وقريت عنا هيك باللي براسيون هيك بفتره
كتبوا عنا يعني والتلفزيون